herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
so kann viel leid und tod vermieden
werden so die eindringlichen worte von
gesundheitsminister sparen vor wenigen
tagen und diesmal war nicht gemeint dass
impfen gegen korona gegen chur wird 19
sondern es geht um die nahende
grippewelle vergangenes jahr dafür die
grippe wegen der vielen corona
schutzmaßnahmen abstand halten kaum mehr
kontakte quasi aus jetzt diesen
kommenden winter könnte sie dafür umso
heftiger ausfallen das sagen einige
experten und entsprechend eindringlich
die warnung und auch die bitte von
gesundheitsminister sparen und auch
lothar wieler dem chef des
robert-koch-instituts sich unbedingt
gegen grippe impfen zu lassen was ist
dann was könnte wirklich passieren wie
heftig kann die grippe welle kommen oder
eben auch nicht wir wollen darüber reden
und ihre fragen beantwortet und ich bin
mir sicher wir werden sie alle
beantworten können denn wir reden mit
einem top experten dem infektiologen
doktor christoph spinner er ist oberarzt
am klinikum rechts der isar in münchen
da schalten wir hin dass uns bei skype
zugeschaltet herr spinner recht
herzlichen dank dass sie sich die zeit
genommen haben schöne namen münchen
guten abend ich grüße sie jetzt fangen
wir einfach mal ich sage mal ganz für
blöde an es kratzt bei mir im hals ich
muss mir die nase putzen ich huste wann
rede ich von einem schnupfen wann sagt
man grippaler infekt da steckt krippe
drin ist das ein grippaler infekt und
wann rede ich von einer grippe um
erstmal die sachen sauber zu
unterscheiden
ich glaube die frage ist sehr gut denn
die sogenannte echte virusgrippe ist
eine erkrankung die eine hoch
fieberhafte schwere erkrankung mit kopf-
glieder- und muskelschmerzen verursacht
und selbst junge menschen schwer krank
machen kann totale infekte hingegen
bezeichneten eine ganze sammle gruppe
verschiedene erreger die leichtere
atemwegsinfektionen vor allem in den
wintermonaten mit husten laufen nase
schnupfen und zum teil natürlich auch
fieberhafte erkrankung verursachen so
ganz ohne labor chemische diagnostik als
echten virus nachweis kann man das nicht
unterschreiben aber ganz allgemein gehen
die faustregel die echte virusgrippe ist
eine schwere erkrankung ein globaler
infekt hingegen meist eine mild des
moderate atemwegsinfektion verursacht
nicht durch die echte virusgrippe
gut dass er das jetzt noch mal definiert
haben wenn es jetzt wirklich mit fieber
gliederschmerzen ein dieb abo also
wirklich eine grippe ist haben dann
sparen und wiler recht wenn sie sagen
das sollte man nicht ganz auf die
leichte schulter nehmen ja absolut der
echte virusgrippe ist eine schwere
erkrankung die auch tatsächlich jedes
jahr viele tausend todesopfer fordert
denn sie betrifft vor allem ältere
menschen betagte menschen und auch im
un- erkrankte menschen oder menschen mit
erkrankungen des immunsystems kann dort
schwerer dollar verursachen in der regel
steht eine schwere lungenentzündung im
vordergrund die häufig auch auf
intensivstationen behandelt werden muss
und es handelt sich um eine
viruserkrankung es stehen uns nur wenige
therapeutika zur verfügung viele
menschen überleben diese erkrankung
tatsächlich bei schwerem verlauf nicht
und deshalb kommt es sehr darauf an sich
zu schützen und dafür ist genau jetzt
der richtige moment um eine
schutzimpfung gegen die echte
virusgrippe influenza auch abzuholen da
kommen wir natürlich unbedingt drauf
noch gleich darauf auf das thema eben
impfungen was man tun kann wir wollen
uns aber auch normalerweise gerade
gesagt haben also grippe ist was völlig
anderes als ein leichter schnupfen der
nach drei wochen wieder weg sondern kann
zu lungenentzündungen kann zur
intensivstation etc führen wir wollen
uns mal anschauen wie denn so ein grippe
verlauf im winter aussieht da haben wir
eine grafik die die grippewelle einfach
mal zeigt in der vergangenheit diese
erste kurve die wir gerade gesehen haben
die dunkelblaue die ganz nach oben
schießt im winter so anfang januar
februar das ist die grippewelle im
winter 2017/18 gewesen da wütete die
grippe also ganz besonders stark in
deutschland schätzungsweise
25.000 tote gabel sind das bestätigt ja
nochmal was sie herr doktor spender
gerade gesagt haben die grippe kann
tödlich enden und das gar nicht mal
allzu selten dann sehen wir die zweite
kurve die sich aufgebaut hat die
schwarze das ist immer noch vor der
korona pandemie der winter 2009 10 20
gewesen das sieht man schon nicht ganz
so steil eine relativ sagen experten
durchschnittliche kurve sozusagen ein
normaler grippe verläuft ja und dann die
orangefarbene kurve das ist der
vergangene coroner winter 20 21 gewesen
da wütete corona alle hielten abstand
maske auf der nase keine kontakte und
das grippevirus hatte damit auch keine
chance die kurve also fragt man kann
sagen die grippewelle blieb dank der
korona maßnahmen einfach aus und sparen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hatte
erklärt dass es eine solche kurve dass
es so etwas seit den aufzeichnungen der
daten noch nicht gegeben hat also kann
man sich freuen ganz links sieht man
einen roten punkt wer genau hinschaut
das sind wir jetzt im oktober und das
ist natürlich ein bisschen jetzt der
blick in die kristallkugel der doktor
spinner wie könnte das ganze denn jetzt
im kommenden winter 21 22 verlaufen
ganz sicher wird der verlauf nicht sein
wie im vergangenen herbst oder in der
vergangenen saison denn sie haben es
schon angesprochen die abstandsregeln
hygiene alltags maske als sie haben dazu
beigetragen dass ich nicht nur 62
schlechter verbreiten konnte sondern
sämtliche atemwegs übertragbaren
erkrankungen denn die
atemwegserkrankungen drehten er vor
allem deshalb in den wintermonaten
verstärkt aus weil wir uns mehr in
innenräumen aufhalten und haupt
übertragungsweg ist ganz ähnlich wie bei
coop 19 die sogenannte aerosole sierung
also kleinste tröpfchen die wir beim
sprechen ausstoßen die sich in
innenräumen ansammeln und mit kleinen
viruspartikeln beladen sind so zu
infektionen führen können also im grunde
freundlich wenn ich jetzt draußen an der
frischen luft spazieren gehe und es ist
kalt und windig und man könnte sagen
da habe ich aber auch nicht im zug
gestanden das ist jetzt gar nicht die
große gefahr sondern es ist ähnlich wie
bei corona in geschlossenen räumen dass
ich die grippe dass ich mich infiziere
durch andere durch die aerosole die
letzten endes das virus dann innerhalb
eines raumes von der einen person zu
anderen bringen er geht auf und wir
sehen auch tatsächlich jetzt schon dass
die
atemwegsinfektionen deutlich zunehmen es
gibt verschiedene sogenannte
surveillance systeme um zu überwachen
wie sich atemwegserkrankungen verändern
und insbesondere bei kleinen kindern vor
allem bei den null- bis vierjährigen
nehmen die atemwegserkrankungen aktuell
deutlich zu es gab zuletzt auch viele
mediale berichte die vor allem von rsv
infektionen eine andere
viruserkrankungen sogenannte
respiratorische
soziallehre des viren bei kindern
berichten dieser erkrankung kann doch
bei kindern schwer verläuft verlaufen
und im krankenhaus behandelt werden
müssen all das sind hinweise dafür dass
die jetzt kommende saison ganz anders
verlaufen wird und es ist in meinen
augen auch sehr klar denn durch die hohe
corona impfquote und den wunsch der
menschen zurück zur normalität vor krone
zurückzukehren finden wieder mehr
soziale kontakte statt und soziale
kontakte sind natürlich immer ein
gewisses risiko bei der übertragung von
atemwegserkrankungen
jetzt ist die frage was ist die lösung
sie haben es schon gesagt impfen sparen
und wieder haben es auch gesagt schauen
wir uns einmal ganz kurz zusammengefasst
in einem bericht einfach an für wen käme
es in frage wäre es ratsam und dann
sprechen wir darüber jedes jahr die
gleiche frage wer sollte sich gegen
grippe impfen lassen die ständige
impfkommission empfiehlt alle personen
ab 60 jahre chronisch kranke schwangere
nach dem dritten monat bei erhöhter
gesundheitlicher gefährdung schon ab dem
ersten monat bewohner von alters- und
pflegeheime aber auch für personen mit
erhöhter gefährdung die medizinisches
personal oder menschen mit vielen
kontakten zum beispiel im einzelhandel
oder gastronomiebereich macht eine
grippeimpfung sinn und was ist mit
kindern viele länder empfehlen dass man
junge kinder impfen sollte man auch da
sieht man schwerere grippe verläuft wie
in deutschland sind ja immer sehr
konservativ mit unseren impfempfehlungen
und empfehlen dass ich würde mal sagen
klammern noch nicht empfohlen wird die
grippeschutzimpfung zwischen oktober bis
dezember
denn in der regel grassiert anfang
januar die grippewelle aufgrund der
korona maßnahmen wie masken tragen und
abstand halten
die aber im vergangenen winter nahezu
aus das heißt aber auch dass im letzten
der letzten saison niemand an ihm unität
entwickeln hat gegen das grippevirus und
normalerweise hilft die uns ja immer
dann die nächste sorgen zu beschränken
deswegen ist gerade jetzt die
grippeimpfung sicherlich sehr sehr
wichtig übrigens ist es kein problem
sich gegen grippe und krone am selben
tag impfen zu lassen spart zeit macht
sinn genauso wie das weitere einhalten
der haarigen so kommen sie sicher durch
den winter
so das war jetzt eigentlich ganz ganz
viel ganz viele informationen auf einen
haufen sozusagen wir drösel dass ein
bisschen jetzt auf mit ihnen dr spinner
fangen wir erstmal mit einer
grundsätzlichen frage an weil wir ja nun
die dinge parallel haben wir haben
corona und jetzt kommt's grippe jetzt
haben wir eben darüber gesprochen erst
mal zu unterscheiden zwischen dem
normalen einfach schnupfen und griffe
wie kann ich denn jetzt aber auch
unterscheiden was ist corona und wann
ist es eine grippe
tatsächlich kann man das anhand der
klinischen symptome also dem
erkrankungsbild eigentlich überhaupt
nicht dafür ist dann erregernachweis
seit kuba das heißt es braucht einen
mund nasen oder rachenabstrich um werden
nachzuweisen ob es sich um corona oder
eine grippe infektion handelt übrigens
auch trotz wegfall der sogenannten
jedermann testung also der
kostenpflichtigkeit von scout24 test ist
es so dass symptomatischer menschen
weiterhin den medizinischen system
zugang zur kostenfreiheit bzw testung zu
lasten der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherungen haben und ich
glaube das ist auch wichtig denn
unverändert kommt der unterbrechung der
kontakt durch übertragung eine ganz
wesentliche rolle zu sprich wer symptome
einer atemwegsinfektion also hohes
fieber husten kopf und gliederschmerzen
hat der sollte natürlich nicht nur zu
hause bleiben sondern im einzelfall
macht es da noch bis in die tiefsten
herauszuschinden liegt eine influenza
oder schafskopf zwei infekte und vor
jetzt kommen schon die ersten fragen
kommen schreibt über youtube sollen
studenten sich auch gegen grippe impfen
lassen also die entscheidende frage am
anfang des beitrags eben auch wer sollte
sich gegen grippe impfen lassen wer
profitiert am meisten davon wo macht es
am meisten sind wirklich den meisten
schutz
ganz vereinfacht ausgedrückt machte
impfung natürlich vergeben sind
insbesondere wird aber empfohlen für
ältere menschen spreche jenseits der
sechzig für menschen mit chronischen
erkrankungen aber auch für menschen die
berufsmäßig viel kontakt zu anderen
haben und auch studierende zumindest
solange sie am campus studieren haben
naturgemäß sehr sehr viele soziale
kontakte
wann immer die möglichkeit der impfung
besteht würde ich ganz klar empfehlen
sie wahrzunehmen
das risiko schwerer infektionen sprecht
mir der notwendigkeit im krankenhaus
behandelt zu werden oder vielleicht im
günstigen fall sogar auf einer
intensivstation steigt aber vor allem
mit dem erkrankungen er mit dem alter
und bei vorerkrankungen
dennoch gerade auch für medizinisches
personal oder menschen in der
öffentlichkeit macht die impfung
natürlich sehen um nicht nur sich selbst
zu schützen sondern auch andere vor
übertragung zu schützen denn die impfung
reduziert neben dem schutz für den
geimpften auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
der übertragung also ich würde mal sagen
eine klare antwort an keiner helfen denn
wer in einen vollen hörsaal geht jetzt
hat das semester wieder angefangen ich
habe wir haben andere beiträge schon den
heute -nachrichten gehabt wie sehr sich
die studenten die studenten freuen auch
wieder in die uni zu gehen und insofern
geht es nicht nur um corona sondern die
grippe möchte man vom nachbarn bei der
vorlesung ja auch nicht bekommen oder an
andere weitergeben jetzt kommt benedikt
hat an mit seiner eigenen erfahrung und
schreibt über youtube ich hatte mal eine
grippe seitdem ich impfe seitdem ich
mich jedes jahr impfen lasse habe ich
keine mehr gehabt also ein beispiel
dafür dass die der schutz dieser
grippeimpfung doch wohl ganz gut ist
kann man denn jetzt irgendwas
statistisch darüber sagen nach dem motto
die grippeschutzimpfungen ist bei
älteren ganz besonders groß oder ist die
bei jüngeren noch erfolgreicher hängt
das auch mit dem immunsystem
zusammen haben wir jetzt ja bei krone
auch viel gelernt dass das immunsystem
bei älteren jahr schwächer ist als bei
jüngeren wie sieht es da aus im grunde
ist es ganz ähnlich über oder auch die
risikogruppen sind sehr vergleichbar
durch ältere menschen haben ein deutlich
höheres risiko dass der impfstoff nicht
vergleichbar gut wirkt es gibt außerdem
verschiedene impfstoffe man muss wissen
die influenza also die echte virusgrippe
bringt mechanismen mit sich um sich der
immunantwort sowohl auf natürliche weise
erworben als auch durch impfungen zu
entziehen mann bezeichnet als das
antigen schrift und kreft vereinfacht
ausgedrückt verändert des virus einfach
seine oberfläche damit die nach impfung
oder infektionen entstanden antikörper
schlechter das virus neutralisieren
können anders als corona ist das eine
strategie des influenza-virus um sich
besser verbreiten zu können und deshalb
gibt es auch verschiedene impfstoffe auf
der einen seite verschiedene subtypen
des influenza stammes es gibt nämlich
sogenannte 3 und 4 fach impfstoffe also
country und tetra valent der impfstoffe
und neu seit diesem jahr ist dass es für
ältere menschen mit risikofaktoren für
schwerer verläufe auch höher dosierte
impfstoffe gibt die in studien deutlich
bessere ansprechraten zeigen konnten
jetzt sind wir genau beim thema eben
impfstoff
stefan moment moment hier oben sind wir
völlig reinhardt muss man auch die
richtige frage haben fragen sie bei
youtube ist der grippe impfstoff auch
für babys schwangere und kinder bis 11
jahre zugelassen
es gibt ganz unterschiedliche impfstoffe
die zur nutzung zur verfügung stehen
anders als die korona impfstoffe stehen
hilfsstoffen seit vielen jahren zur
verfügung
weitere treffen aus ksb impfstoff für
schwangere sicher eingesetzt werden kann
und so ähnlich wie bei corona wissen wir
auch dass schwangere ein deutlich
erhöhtes risiko von schweren verläufen
einer echten influenza also echten
virusgrippe haben und deshalb machte
impfung insbesondere nach den ersten
zwölf wochen ziehen es gibt auch
impfstoffe für kinder aber so wie meine
kollegin ulrike protzer beitrag erwähnt
hat ist es so dass wir in deutschland
regelhaft keine kinder in mindestbreite
sofern keine vorerkrankungen bekannt
sind impfen es gibt aber länder die tun
das und deshalb gibt es hier auch etwas
geringer dosierte aber zugelassene
impfstoffe für kinder
so wir sehen dass alle dr spinner ist
nicht eingefroren denn wir hören ihn
auch noch und ist quicklebendig in
münchen nur die skype leitung die
funktioniert nicht ganz so sehr
jedenfalls hatte ein charmantes bild von
ihnen und hören sie weiterhin mal
schauen vielleicht klappt das mit der
leitung auch gleich wieder und wir sehen
sie dann auch bewegt aber wir wollen es
trotzdem nutzen dass wir sie hören
können und da habe ich die frage an sie
mir hat mal ein arzt gesagt ach lassen
sie sich mal gar nicht so früh also
jetzt sagen wir mal im oktober gegen
grippe impfen sondern warten sie mal so
ein bisschen dann wird der impfstoff
irgendwie noch angepasst und dann weiß
man genau wie der impfstoff sein muss
ist das so dass der an dem impfstoff
noch gearbeitet wird oder ist es der
gleiche impfstoff den mann im oktober im
november oder dezember bekommt
die frage ist sehr gut dahinter
verbergen sich zwei teil einer antwort
zum einen legt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation anhand von
modellrechnungen bereits im sommer fest
wie wahrscheinlich die influenza
ausbreitung in den wintermonaten
aussehen wird und dann werden die
impfstoffe bereits produziert bei den
influenza impfstoffen handelt es sich um
tod impfstoffe die mehrheitlich in
hühnereiern gezüchtet werden als ein
technisch sehr aufwendiges verfahren was
auch viele monate der produktion in
anspruch nimmt das bedeutet impfstoffe
für die aktuelle saison sind längst
produziert können auch nicht mehr so
einfach angepasst werden
ihr arzt hat aber dennoch rechts den sie
hatten vor in dem beitrag ausgeführt
dass die schwerste influenza ausbreitung
zeit in der regel in den ersten
januarwochen erfolgt und wir hatten auch
darüber gesprochen dass die
pflanzenstoffe unterschiedliche wirksam
sind sprich wenn man sich etwas später
also im november anfang dezember impfen
lässt ist das meist für die in trance
noch ausreichend aber gerade die
menschen die ein höheres risiko schwerer
verläufe haben sollten sich bereits
jetzt impfen lassen denn auch wenn im
moment die influenza zahlen in
deutschland
anteilig an den atemwegsinfektionen noch
bei deutlich unter einem prozent legen
kann sich dies natürlich rasch ändern
also wer dann sollen geimpft ist hat
sozusagen vorgesorgt so wir sehen sie
auch wieder im bewegtbild das ist ja
auch etwas charmanter freuen wir uns
dass das wieder klappt jetzt stellt sich
ja wir sind ja alle so ein bisschen zu
virologen halb experten geworden weil
der korona krise was corona was die
pandemie angeht da reden wir von
herdenimmunität was sozusagen immer
angestrebt worden ist die andere
knifflige frage ob es erreicht kann man
denn bei der grippe innerhalb eines
winters auch eine gewisse
herdenimmunität erreichen dass derjenige
dann am ende auch geschützt wird keine
gruppe bekommt der am ende auch gar
nicht geimpft ist
mit dem phänomen der herdenimmunität
wird im grunde ein zustand beschrieben
das sind der bevölkerung so viele
menschen geben sind dass sich das virus
nicht mehr ausbreiten kann die e
mobilität wird nach aus einem einfachen
faktor der einer einfachen formel
errechnet nämlich 1 - 1 durch wobei er 0
für die sogenannte basis
reproduktionsrate eines erregers steht
tatsächlich ist es so dass in
deutschland in der regel keine
herdenimmunität gegenüber influenza
erreicht wird weil sich dafür viel zu
wenige menschen impfen lassen und ich
hatte vorhin schon erwähnt die
influenzaviren sind durch veränderungen
ihrer oberfläche in der lage sich der
immunantwort auch nach impfungen zu
entziehen und all diese faktoren haben
einfluss auf die erde im monat aber
dennoch im kleinen ist es möglich die
menschen zu schützen die sich durch eine
schutzimpfung selbst nicht gut schützen
können das sind zum beispiel menschen
mit hämatologischen grunderkrankungen
also grund erkrankungen des
blutbildenden systems die darauf
angewiesen sind dass die menschen um sie
herum sich durch impfungen schützen und
dadurch das risiko des instruments
eintrags in den haushalt reduzieren und
ich glaube dieser punkt ist ganz wichtig
den ersten beitrag so nicht explizit
angesprochen worden auch angehörige von
menschen mit chronischen erkrankungen
sollten sie sich unbedingt impfen lassen
wir haben viele fragen und antworten ich
will nur einen kleinen hinweis machen
auch im netz wir können wir hier auf
meinem laptop schalten
und hierauf zdf heute.de haben wir
problemlos gegen grippe und cupid 19
impfen sachen hängen ja ein bisschen
zusammen man kann das ja auch parallel
machen also hier werden fragen auch
beantwortet wie man zum beispiel kann
man jetzt sich gegen grippe und corona
gleichzeitig impfen lassen etc da werden
viele fragen beantwortet ich rolle
absichtlich runter weil es hier das
zitat von ingrid genschel gibt vom
deutschen hausärzteverband und sie sagt
diese grippe saison wird sehr
wahrscheinlich stärker ausfallen als die
letzte und sie selber herr doktor
spieler haben schon angeschnitten
nämlich diesen punkt dass es sehr viel
mehr atemwegsinfekte unter kindern
gegeben hat als übliches in den
vergangenen wochen ich denke dass selbst
und meine eigene tochter die ganze kita
sozusagen höchste rum im august und die
kinderärzte haben gesagt die
kinderkliniken hätten bereits engpässe
gehabt und eine erklärung der
kinderärzte ist eben gewesen durch die
korona maßnahmen seien die kinder eben
weniger im kontakt mit
krankheitserregern gekommen weil eben
schulen kitas auch zu wahren etc und
jetzt kommen sie wieder in kontakt und
holen sozusagen die infekte nach heißt
das dass die vertreterin des der
hausärzte insofern recht hat wenn sie
prognostiziert die grippewelle wird wohl
stärker werden in diesem winter weil
durch die korona maßnahmen wir alle
sozusagen
immunsystem nicht mehr so richtig fit
gehalten haben und wir insofern
sozusagen da offener sind wenn wir jetzt
der grippewelle begegnen
ich sehe das ganz und gar genau gleich
wie die kolleginnen denn der grund es
gar nicht so sehr dass unser immunsystem
selbst in der funktionalität
eingeschränkt ist aber die sogenannten
respiratorischen erreger also die
atemwegserkrankung wir mit die für die
zu genauso wie die influenza es sind
leider nicht mit einer dauerhaften
immunität vergesellschaftet es bedeutet
wenn man einmal dieser erkrankung hatte
ist man nicht das ganze leben geschützt
wie dies bei anderen erkrankungen der
fall ist sondern man kann sich das so
vorstellen dass das immunsystem eine art
teilschutz mit sich bringt und je länger
man keinen kontakt mehr mit den erregern
wie zum beispiel der in schwerin sa
hatte des br vergisst unser immunsystem
auch dass wir diesen erreger bereits
kennen und eine spezifische immunantwort
darauf bereitstellen können das heißt
normalerweise findet in gewisser art und
weise so etwas wie eine natürliche
musterung stadt dadurch dass wir in den
wintermonaten kontakt mit vielen
atemwegserkrankung erregern haben baut
sich in der bevölkerung eine art
hintergrund schutz auf und der sorgt
natürlich dafür dass sich dann in der
folgenden saison erreger auch schlechter
verbreiten können so ist das meist so
dass nach einer sehr schweren
grippewelle wie wir sie zum beispiel
auch vor einigen jahren gesehen hatten
die nächste saison meist sehr viel
milder ausfällt weil sehr viel mehr
menschen bereits zumindest noch
teilweise immun gegen diese erreger sind
und diesen hauser umgekehrt sein und
genau jetzt sind wir genau in der
umgekehrten situation und deshalb ist
die gefahr dass die jetzt kommen die
influenza saison besonders schwer wird
sehr hoch gerade deshalb können wir mit
den impfungen gegen steuern manch einer
könnte jetzt sagen na ja gut dann ist
das der normale weg ein winter sehr viel
grippekranke ein weniger einen winter
dann weniger etc aber das wäre der
normale verlauf aber wenn ich ihre
kolleginnen und kolleginnen ja richtig
verstehe die experten die waren eben
davor es ist nicht die grippe alleine
aber wenn wir ganz viele grippekranke
auf intensivstationen haben und auch
noch corona kranke auf intensivstationen
dann könnte sozusagen das fass zum
überlaufen kommen richtig
ja all das spielt natürlich zusätzlich
eine rolle dass auch die
versorgungssituation in den
krankenhäusern dann zusätzlich unter
druck kommen könnte denn in vielen
kliniken sind bereits jetzt etliche
corona patienten wieder in
intensivstationen behandelt werden
müssen und wir sind es gewohnt dass in
den wintermonaten also auch vor caron
eine größere anzahl an der cote patient
mit atemwegsinfektionen versorgt werden
muss kommen diese beiden aber zusammen
dann stehen in vielen regionen nicht
mehr genug intensivbetten zur verfügung
und völlig abgesehen davon glaube ich
kann jeder gut auf die behandlung auf
der intensivstation verzichten die
schutzimpfung gegen influenza ist ein
einfaches und wirksames mittel dagegen
und dauert genau eine sekunde einen keks
ein aufenthalt auf der intensivstation
sicherlich etwas länger nun gibt es
allerdings auch experten die sagen nein
also man kann ja unterschiedliche
meinung haben die einen experten sagen
also die grippewelle dürfte dieses jahr
stärker werden es gibt aber auch andere
die sagen nein weil ja eben auch noch
weiterhin dieser corona maßnahmen
stattfinden weil wir ja auch vielleicht
weiterhin masken tragen vorsichtiger
geworden sind im umgang weniger kontakte
haben die hände mehr desinfizieren etc
stefan es schreibt über youtube ist es
vielleicht dann auch möglich dass uns
die noch vorhandene masken pflicht auch
vor der grippewelle schützt also mit
anderen worten die kurve die grippewelle
doch flacher bleibt dieses jahr
definitiv schützt die masken pflichten
und die asl regeln denn sie schützen
nicht nur von krones und besucher der
sich auch vor anderen
atemwegserkrankungen erregern und das
kommt mir letztes jahr gut sehen auch
letztes jahr war eine große diskussion
um die möglichkeit eines schweren
influenza verlauf es entfacht durch die
einhaltung der regeln und auf der
anderen seite einer sehr hohen impfquote
auch schon im letzten jahr spielte den
schwenzer fast keine rolle anders dieses
jahr ist oder in dieser saison dass ein
großteil der menschen bereits kohl geben
stößt und deswegen ein viel größerer
teil des sozialen lebens wie der stadt
findet es gibt mittlerweile ja nicht nur
restaurants sondern auch klubs die
wieder geöffnet haben also orte an denen
viele hundert menschen zusammen kommen
und auch ohne maske sich wieder treffen
das ist doch gut so und ich kann das als
mediziner auch gut verstehen bedeutet
aber im umkehrschluss ist man auch dass
wir die influenza- gerade für die
menschen die ein hohes risiko schwerer
verläufe haben nicht vernachlässigen
dürfen und hier deshalb auch der ganz
klaren appell die möglichkeit der
impfung jetzt dann warten wahrzunehmen
also das ist im grunde schon ein
bisschen die antwort auf die frage wo
würden wir uns denn in diesem winter
sehr wahrscheinlich dann mit der grippe
anstecken wenn ich sie also richtig
verstehe ist wenn wir weiterhin die
maske tragen
abstand halten dann können wir auch der
grippe aus dem weg gehen aber verstehe
ich sie eben richtig wenn wir hingehen
und sagen ich bin ja doppelt geimpft der
andere ist auch doppelt geimpft wir
gehen ins restaurant ziehen die maske
aus und essen gemeinsam dann ist es
keine dann ist vielleicht das corona
risiko geringer aber sozusagen das
grippevirus kann sich freuen
ich glaube es recht einfach alle
maßnahmen die gegen eine oder vor einer
infektion schützen schützen in gleichem
maße auch vor anderen respiratorischen
als atemwegserkrankungen insbesondere
auch der in friends hat dem echten
grippe virus und deshalb solange die
masken pflicht auch diese saison
beispielsweise auch in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und anderen orten wo
viele menschen zusammenkommen gilt ist
das risiko relevant erniedrigt aber
immer dort wo die masten pflicht eben
nicht mehr gilt da steigt das risiko
auch und es spielten eine rolle dass die
letzte clippers saison so wenig
infektionen mit sich brachte das heißt
wirklich nur ein kleiner teil der
menschen tun ist und ebenso wie bei
krone gibt es auch hier die möglichkeit
neben der immunität der infektion eine
immunität durch impfung zu erreichen und
genau darüber sprechen wie im moment
jetzt haben wir natürlich laufend weiter
neue fragen bekommen anonym schreibt
über youtube ist es nicht so dass das
immunsystem nach überstandener
erkrankung gestellt wird das haben sie
gerade netz erklärt das ist es ja eben
wenn man eine große starke grippewelle
hatte ist es eben üblich dass das
immunsystem dann ein bisschen gestärkt
ist und die grippewelle im nächsten
winter flacher ist jens eppler schreibt
über youtube sind sie gerade mit grippe
zu hause wir wünschen trotzdem gute
besserung habe aber einen schutzimpfung
termin nächste woche freitag muss ich
den verschieben ganz praktische frage
also wenn die echte grippe infektion
bestätigt ist das heißt eine labor
chemische diagnostik zum beispiel aus
dem nasen oder rachenabstrich gemacht
ist dann macht eine impfung jetzt zu
unmittelbar nach der erkrankung
wahrscheinlich keine zimmer empfiehlt er
ganz allgemein etwas abstand zu echten
grippe erkrankungen beziehungsweise
schweren infekt erkrankungen zu halten
aber an der stelle ist mir auch wichtig
hervorzuheben banane grippale infekte
sind keine kontraindikation gegen
schutzimpfungen deswegen in seinem fall
mit dem virus grippe wirklich bestätigt
ist dann mindestens 14 tage abstand
lassen ich habe einfach einen ausgeführt
ausgeführt es gibt verschiedene krippe
stämme die sich ausbreiten man
unterscheidet den schülern zeigen a und
b subtypen und diese wiederum in weitere
untersuchungen und die impfung kann
durchaus noch sinn machen aber erst nach
vollständiger genesung
jetzt eine frage die sich natürlich auch
irgendwo auftreten kann man sich
hingegen corona und grippe gleichzeitig
impfen lassen der eine art sagt na ja da
muss ein abstand sein sparen und wieder
erinnere ich mich daran vor wenigen
tagen haben aber gesagt das kann man
auch gleich am gleichen tag machen was
würden sie denn empfehlen
tatsächlich kann man das am gleichen tag
machen es gibt überhaupt keinen grund
weshalb man schutzimpfungen nicht
gemeinsam verabreichen kann kinder
erhalten heute
56789 fach impfstoffe und es gibt sehr
gute studiendaten die sogar zeigen dass
mancher impfstoffe wenn sie gemeinsam
verabreicht werden die immunantwort
sogar noch verstärken also besser
schützen wer jetzt seine krone impfungen
oder eine krone auffrischungsimpfung
erhalten soll und grippe geimpft werden
soll kann diese am gleichen tag machen
wichtig ist nur wenn nicht am gleichen
tag gewünscht wird dann soll betont
impfstoffen und dazu gehören cola und
grippeimpfstoffe mindestens ein abstand
nicht schätzen tagen gehalten werden
werden sie am gleichen tag verabreicht
ist es nicht erforderlich
ok also das ist eine ganz ganz
entscheidende sache dass man sollte also
jetzt vermeiden dass sich am montag
gegen korona geimpft werde und am
mittwoch gegen grippe wenn ich beides am
montag bekomme dann sozusagen verläuft
das alles parallel und dann mit sehr gut
oder man macht es halt in einer distanz
von 14 tage in einem abstand
sodann
bedeutet ist mit seinem namen vielleicht
ein bisschen an dass er ein bisschen an
der konträre meinung jetzt zu ihnen
einfach mal kommt über youtube schreibt
der dickkopf ist es denn nicht besser
dass jeder mal eine grippe durch machen
sollte stichwort stärkung der
abwehrkräfte und ist es nicht so dass
man eine grippe sich nicht immer dass
man eine grippe nicht immer vermeiden
kann trotz impfung
also zum ersten teil der antwort
tatsächlich gibt es überhaupt keine
hinweise darauf dass eine natürliche
überstandenen infektion mit einer
besseren oder gar gestärkten e-mobilität
einhergeht als immunität durch
schutzimpfung im gegenteil sie haben
vorhin ja gesagt zum teil mehrere
zehntausend
grippetote pro saison alleine in
deutschland
ich glaube man muss sich auch darüber im
klaren sein dass die grippe eine
ernstzunehmende erkrankung ist und in
einem relevanten anteil der betroffenen
auch tödlich verlaufen kann und das gilt
übrigens auch für jüngere menschen
auf der anderen seite und das war der
zweite teil der frage kann ich mich
trotz impfung infizieren ja das ist
möglich denn keine schutzimpfung schützt
zu 100 es gibt verschiedene faktoren die
eine rolle spielt das alter hatten wir
waren schon angesprochen aber auch der
eingesetzte impfstoff seine dosierung
und die tatsache welche grippestämme
dann tatsächlich zirkulieren denn ich
hatte das eingangs schon und er in einem
beitrag zuvor diskutiert anders als
corona wie ein verliebtes grippevirus
über ein ganzes arsenal aus mechanismen
um sich der impfung entsprechend zu
entziehen und wenn die subtypen die dann
entsprechend zirkulieren in der saison
nicht so gut von der impfung erfasst
sind steigt das risiko zusätzlich diese
frage können wir aber heute noch nicht
beantworten trotzdem eben ein ganz ganz
ganz klares plädoyer und ich glaube wir
haben es ja bereits zitiert in der
saison 2017 18 in dem winter
25.000 tote durch die grippe in
deutschland
das ist eine klare zahl und an der ist
auch nicht zu rütteln das ist glaube ich
eine deutliche antwort wie ernst die
grippe zu nehmen ist das unterstreicht
das was sie gesagt haben wenn wir also
jetzt überzeugt sind und sagen jawohl
der herr doktor spinner hat recht also
schnell zum hausarzt ich möchte mich
gegen grippe impfen lassen dann scheint
es anscheinend dann doch wohl jedes jahr
so ein bisschen auch bei dem impfen
einen gewissen verlauf zu geben ein
hausarzt berichtet über folgendes sage
ich mal phänomen oder wir folgendes
problem hören wir einfach mal kurz rein
die politik verspricht uns dass der
impfstoff reichen wird es wird
wahrscheinlich auch reichen weil das ist
bislang jedes jahr so gewesen dass
impfstoff zum schluss noch übrig war
allerdings hoffe ich dass dieser
impfstoff auch schon jetzt in den ersten
wochen komplett parat steht weil im
letzten jahr hatten wir die erfahrung
gemacht dass war wenigen wochen ich
glaube wir uns waren zweieinhalb wochen
der impfstoff dann auswahl und wir die
patienten vertrösten mussten und viele
sind dann erst im dezember geimpft
worden als dann größere impfstoff
lieferung wieder kamen
das betreibt ein hausarzt aus
niedersachsen also jetzt muss man
vielleicht dazu sagen dass
gesundheitsminister sparen angekündigt
hat dieses jahr in diesem winter stehen
27 millionen impfdosen bereit so viele
wie noch nie einfach nur mal zur
einordnung zum vergleich im letzten jahr
im chor oder winter 20 21 waren sind 22
millionen dosen verimpft worden also 27
deutlich mehr steht jetzt zur verfügung
und in normalen vor corona wintersaison
sind so um die 15 17 millionen dosen
verimpft worden also 27 millionen
impfdosen stehen bereit wenn er wie
jetzt sagt ja am anfang ist vielleicht
ein run auf die hausarztpraxis und dann
muss man warten bis die nächste charge
irgendwie kommt was würden sie sagen ist
es wichtig jetzt möglichst schnell zum
hausarzt oder würden sie sagen na ja
einfach ruhe und geduld und jetzt nicht
die hausarztpraxis stürmen wenn es dann
eben erst im november wird dann ist ja
auch gut
wie gesagt normalerweise kann der pike
influenza saison im januar erwartet
werden es kann natürlich den einzelnen
jahren auch schon mal anders sein und
bereits im dezember beginnen ursächlich
ist der vor allem der übertragungsweg
über den innenraum aufenthalt ich glaube
die frühe impfung macht ihr 10 für
menschen die chronisch krank sind die
über 60 jahre alt sind die wirklich auf
die schutzwirkung des impfstoffes
angewiesen sind für alle anderen spielt
es sich ja auch keine rolle wenn die
impfung erst im november oder anfang
dezember erfolgt übrigens gibt's ja
nicht nur die möglichkeit sich beim
hausarzt impfen zu lassen auch viele
betriebsärzte innen und betrieb bieten
die möglichkeit der impfung nicht nur
für mitarbeiter im gesundheitswesen aber
auch zum teil den großen industriefirmen
und hier macht es ja auch sinn
vielleicht die haushalts praxis
dahingehend zu entlasten das ist sich um
die chronisch kranken und die ältere
menschen bevorzugt kümmern kann und
gleichzeitig verschiedene zugänge
genutzt werden kann ich glaube ein ganz
ganz ganz ganz wichtiger hinweis den die
hausärzte jetzt auch gerne hören werden
uns dieser haushalt sehen wir gerade
gehört haben in niedersachsen mit
sicherheit auch also schon mal eine
wichtige information ganz zum schluss
einfach mal noch eine neugierige frage
die mir gekommen ist so eine
grippeschutzimpfung könnte die wir leben
wir jetzt auf einmal in zeiten wo wir
corona und grippe parallel dann haben
kann denn eine grippeschutzimpfung
sozusagen auch zusätzlich neben einer
corona impfung auch noch mal gegen cupid
19 helfen
die frage wurde im letzten jahr intensiv
diskutiert machte müsst tatsächlich in
einzelnen beobachtungsstudien zunächst
scheinbarer hinweise gab dass ist aber
hat sich so nicht bestätigt denn unser
immunsystem funktioniert im grunde nach
einem schlüssel schloss prinzip dh
erreger sowie influenza oder skoda virus
zwei werden hochspezifisch erkannt
deswegen schützt die grippeimpfung nicht
vor corona virusinfektionen aber es wird
natürlich daran gearbeitet diese beiden
impfstoffe zusammen zu bringen und
vielleicht in zukunft auch in allen das
spritzen verabreichen zu können also es
wird weiter geforscht aber wir fassen
zusammen
ein ganz klares plädoyer eben auch von
ihnen und mit besten erklärungen
untermauert warum wir uns gegen grippe
impfen sollten warum durchaus ein
heftigerer verlauf als im vergangenen
winter zu erwarten ist und insofern eine
impfung ein kleiner pieks sinnvoll wäre
und vielen vielen dank auch für die
tipps dass es eben nicht nur der
haushalts ist dem mann belagern muss um
an die impfdosis zu kommen sondern dass
es ja auch noch andere wege gibt vielen
vielen dank für die vielen vielen
antworten ich glaube wir haben alle
fragen beantwortet wir sagen insofern
ein großes großes dankeschön an sieger
doktor spinner nach münchen wünschen
weiterhin gute arbeit und kommen sie
auch gut durch diesen grippe winter
wären wir gern ich danke ihnen alles
gute und bleibende gesund dankeschön
also ja dr spinner sagt bleiben sie
gesund das haben wir bisher in der
korona pandemie gesagt immer denken tan
kopitz 19
wie wichtig es ist dass auch ernst zu
nehmen dass man gesund bleiben soll und
etwas dafür tun kann was das thema
grippe angeht haben wir jetzt besprochen
noch mal der hinweis eben auf zdf heute
haben wir auch viel im netz zu dem thema
grippe grippeschutzimpfungen parallel
das ganze zu corona was man tun sollte
und was zu raten ist ja das war zdf
heute live unser live stream zum thema
grippe und ich schließe mich den
wünschen von doktor spinner aus münchen
an und sage bleiben sie gesund machen
sie es gut schön dachte